dans la famille microsoft je demande le
surface du o2 souvenez vous souvenez
vous on était au moins de mars 2021
données morteau son surface duo première
version et j'étais extrêmement déçu et
microsoft revient moins d'un an après
avec un tout nouveau produit alors moins
d'un an après il faut savoir que la
surface duo première génération était
représentée en 2019 est sorti aux us en
2020 et en france en 2021 avec un
processeur daté et là ils nous
reviennent avec un tout nouveau produit
que c'est le surface duo 2 de surface
duo de il est super intéressant parce
qu'il est extrêmement différents c'est
pas pour autant qu'il va être fait pour
nous pique on va essayer de comprendre à
qui est destiné qu'est ce qu'on va faire
avec il ya une nouvelle couleur c'est
déjà pas mal il ya plein de nouvelles
choses eu plein de belles améliorations
microsoft a vraiment bien travaillé sur
ce produit
1599 euros
1599 euros on va essayer de comprendre à
1599 euros qu'est ce que vous avez
qu'est ce que vous allez pouvoir faire
de ce produit que ce produit est
introduit qui explique et très
particulier mais qui aussi assez cool et
qui fait plein de jolies promesses et ça
ça me plaît alors on y va
[Musique]
beaucoup étaient des produits très très
très différents et là pour le coup c'est
très très très très différent et cette
pile vote d'un côté de lot s'adapte à
vous se serait tu as plein plein de
choses alors le premier truc à voir ici
cette forme regardez c'est la finesse de
ce produit c'est tellement fin par
rapport à un doigt c'est absolument
incroyable regarder la finesse du truc
c'est vraiment ce qu'ils avaient
beaucoup séduit avec la première version
sur la version précédente vous avez une
seule caméra c'était la caméra de saïfi
qui étaient ici là ils ont corrigé
l'histoire et ils ont fait un vrai
appareil photo aucune vraie caméra au dr
c'est intéressant oui et non parce que
ça vient rajouter quand même un petit
peu en termes d'épaisseur on pourrait
dire ouais tu chipote mon bon monsieur
heureux c'est vrai je chipote c'est mon
job de chipoter et lorsque vous venez
vous amuser que vous en rajoutez un peu
malade et vous pensez là alors pour
autant je pince mais ça ne bouge pas
l'écran reste en lice parce qu'en fait
votre blog photos il vient toucher la
partie juste en face si on pourrait dire
l'avenir swabi messi soit rayé leurs
habits mais la partie de l'appareil
photo en fait non le contour plastique
est un peu plus haut que la partie à
vitré de l'appareil photo on a pas de
risque de devenir endommagé ici set
partait donc ça ça me va par contre
c'est vrai que à terme alors je n'ai pas
testé suffisamment longtemps faudra
utiliser pendant plusieurs mois pour se
rendre compte si ça risque d'abîmer de
venir taper comme ça voyez donc pour
l'instant j'ai pas de marque mieux vaut
y aller doucement mais vous savez un
truc ça se prend sa chance mais comme ça
sa vie en fait un smartphone alors on
peut pas tout avoir je me plaignais sur
l'ancienne version qui est pas
d'appareil photo l'arrière ici en un et
on va se regarder salle en quelques
instants vous allez hop le résultat est
assez intéressant est que microsoft a
bien bossé là dessus alors y'a un truc
qui est aussi assez marrant c'est le
format pasco gras smartphones y regarder
on le met dans une poche des fois là
lorsque je le mets dans ma poche ça
fonctionne pas trop mal sauf qu'ici j'ai
un truc qui très pointu pas très évident
à vous montrer c'est que comme ici j'ai
un angle et bien ça va venir munich et
tous mes jeans alors vous me direz pour
obliger de le mettre dans un jean ouais
je sais c'est évident mais comme on est
une partie en bulleuse la voyez c'est
tout qui est un peu dommage ont quelque
part dans une poche ces trucs un peu
moyen bon c'est vraiment un sens de
venir chercher le petit peu de détails
et l'autre point comme on avait sur
l'autre version est bien c'est qu'elle
est quand même assez grande et pour
tenir à une main c'est pas évident c'est
un produit qui est vraiment pas vu comme
étant un smartphone de la part de
microsoft mais comme un objet portatif
qui servira pour la productivité c'est
un petit microsoft de poche 1 donc on va
avoir un peu d'épaisseur et on pourrait
se dire quand le tenant demain c'est pas
ouf j'ai pas des mains extrêmement
grande si vous avez de très grands
demain sera encore plus facile pour vous
mais c'est vrai que c'est un produit qui
est un petit peu grand il fait 2 184 g
en termes de poids bon ça va ça me
dérange pas bien méchant tout j'adore
ici c'est cette charnière je l'adoré
déjà sur la première version on a une
sensation de solidité on voit que
microsoft a mis les moyens ici a fait un
produit qui est vraiment super bowl la
charnière est superbe est maintenant il
ya un truc qui est intéressant mais sur
lequel j'avais beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup critiqué microsoft pour cette
première génération c'était toute la
partie logicielle parce qu'elle était
plein de bugs il ya des choses qui
n'allaient pas alors je vous le dis ça
reste vraiment pas parfait c'est un
produit qu'on va pas venir utiliser
emmenant m une des applications en grand
écran les seules applications qu'on va
venir mettre en grand écran et bien ça
va être par exemple un outlook donc je
le prends au plat je le mets au milieu
ça c'est vachement bien en termes
d'usagé tout ça vraiment vraiment super
bien pour avoir mon agenda pour me
regarder également des images et la
liste de mes emails à gauche et je vais
avoir le détail de mon email à droite
s'est extrêmement bien que rêve pour
tous ces usages vraiment dédié microsoft
c'est super intéressant pour venir
utiliser ouvrir deux applications en
même temps par exemple du divertissement
à gauche je vais avoir mon instagram et
à droite vermont spotify donc ça c'est
aussi relativement intéressant prête
pour venir ici faire du multitâche c'est
totalement optimisé j'ai mon tiroir
d'applications et une animation qui est
vraiment beaucoup mieux faites par
rapport à ce qu'on avait avant regardez
en bas j'ai une espèce de barre des
tâches avec toutes les applications et
lorsque j'ouvre un terrain d'application
et bien le viennent sur le côté et ça
c'est très sympa c'est extrêmement
fluide ya un côté très intuitif on est
basé sur android 11 donc bon pas de
grande surprise c'est très efficace et
pour tous vos logiciels microsoft ça va
être vraiment bien c'est ça qui est
intéressant avec ce produit fait faillir
tablette c'est qu'en fait c'est un
produit qui est créé par microsoft pour
du microsoft regarder la même manière je
vais ouvrir mes paramètres ici et
paramètres ils vont pas être intéressant
là ils vont être intéressant si je les
mets au milieu pourquoi bien parce que
sur la partie de gauche je veux avoir
mon menu et sur la partie droite je vais
avoir mes détails par exemple ici au
fond d'écran la sécurité la localisation
une fois de plus il a un vrai sens à
venir l'utiliser comme ça par contre si
je dis regardez une vidéo comme ça en
plein écran me voyez ça ne marche pas
donc pour me regarder des vidéos il faut
que je le switch que je le mec comme ça
et pas en plein écran parce que c'est
pareil ça ne fonctionne pas je le laisse
comme ça et là je peux venir regarder
une vidéo je vais avoir en bas ma liste
de vidéos à regarder après et mes
commentaires donc là il ya un sens et là
ça fonctionne mais autrement ça pas de
la même manière sur netflix ça va être
exactement la même chose je vais pas
venir me regarder un film une série
comme ça je ne le regardais sur une
partie de l'écran et de côté je vais
pouvoir surfer sur internet mais
attention il ya en tout cas connaître
quand même ici qui est pas ouf regardez
par exemple si je me mets une série là
sur le haut sur netflix ok je veux bien
et si sur le bateau mené par exemple le
plextor et que je me cherchais une
application est bien ok je peux venir le
faire sauf que si j'appuie la up qu'est
ce qui se passe est bien le haut ça
dégage parce que mon clavier va arriver
en bas donc ça c'est pas complètement
pratique donc si je veux venir regarder
j'en sais rien dans un tuto sur youtube
me prendre des notes en dessous je peux
pas le faire si je veux le faire pour
que je passe on note format que je me
mette comme ça l'agent la vidéo en plus
petit et là je vais pouvoir venir taper
ce que je veux et à ce sujet regardez il
ya un truc qui marche pas très très bien
c'est ici là le clavier il ya une petite
partie qui est tronqué ici et ça c'est
un peu dommage je les d'un côté et de
l'autre j'aurais préféré que mon clavier
vienne jusqu'au bout pour à des touches
un peu plus grand ici j'ai pas et c'est
quand même un peu ballot puisque je vous
parlais des photos il ya un truc est
très intéressant sur ce qu'a fait
microsoft au niveau des photos c'est le
fait d'avoir intégré un vrai appareil
photo oui on peut venir ici prendre une
photo et en même temps regarder les
photos qu'on a fait avant pourrait venir
comparer si vous le souhaitez pourquoi
pas on a un petit zoom x de haut niveau
de la caméra de celle fille why not et
de l'autre côté et bien regarder si vous
le prenez vous voulez le plier pour
faire des photos il switch directement
sur la caméra cette fille parce que là
vous allez bloquer l'appareil photo si
vous re détendez vous pouvez mais voilà
il ya une petite limite le truc à savoir
ici c'est que si vous voulez faire des
photos en le posant comme ça et bien
vous pouvez savourer votre petite photo
l'arrière ça vous servira de petit
cheval et vous mettez retardateur vous
prenez vos photos faites vos vidéos ce
que vous et donc pour faire aussi de la
création c'est assez rigolo en terme
d'expérience logiciel on peut venir zoom
est comme ça très facilement si vous le
mettez en plein écran vous allez voir
vos photos sur le côté pour venir voir
ce que vous avez fait donc ça c'est
assez rigolo aussi pourquoi pas et puis
surtout ici vous avez vrai appareil
photo vous avez un grand-angle plus
ouvre à f un point cette première point
savoir si vous avez stabilisation
optique sur votre grand angle et sur
votre télé objectif lorsque vous allez
venir prendre des photos avec et bien
c'est complètement stabilisé ça c'est
bien vous avez 12 mégapixels son grand
angle 12 mégapixels sur le téléobjectif
on ouvre à f 1.7 sur le grand temps et
on ouvre à f 2.4 l objectif et puis vous
avez un ultra grand-angle de 16
mégapixels touvre f 2.2 ici aucune
stabilisation des saints paraît normal
vous avez un champ de vision de 110
degrés avec une correction de la
distorsion talent équivalent 13 mm et
sur le grand angle au téléobjectif
vous avez un autofocus à détection de
phase duel pixels et vous pouvez venir
faire de la vidéo jusqu'en cas à 60
images par seconde donc c'est vraiment
le jour et la nuit par rapport à ce
qu'on avait sur la première version de
ce produit là soyons clair ici ce
smartphone n'est pas un photophone et
vous pouvez voir directement au niveau
des rendus sur la caméra principale le
rendu sera assez correcte va pas voir
des photos et mandingue on peut venir se
rapprocher en ainsi un zoom optique x 2
on peut aller jusqu'aux feux 10 mais
faut-il y aller je ne suis pas sûr
regardez c'est devient relativement
imprécis c'est pas terrible ici c'est un
x 4 on va jusqu'au 10 mai non c'est
vraiment pas fait pour ça on perd
vraiment précision avec à cet ultra
grand-angle mais je dirai rien de bien
surprenant ici une fois de plus ce n'est
pas un photophone quand on est habitué à
voir des smartphones qui sont
extrêmement flatteur au niveau de la
photo à des algorithmes avec de l'ia là
on ne l'a pas caméra principale l'ultra
grand-angle et très terne et c'est pas
ouf de ce côté là on vient se rapprocher
le traitement est pas fou donc je ne
vous recommande pas et enfin glissement
parlons absolument pas la caméra de
celle ci ne fait pas des miracles non
plus le rendu n'est pas très très beau
au niveau de la peau vous le voyez il ya
un côté un peu cireux au niveau de la
peau et voilà n'ont globalement pas du
tout le mode portrait bon si on veut
mais c'est pas mal non plus et
uniquement logiciels et politiques ici
donc rien d'exceptionnel sur la caméra
celle ci vous pouvez en plus venir zone
est ici c'est le voisin et vous pouvez
bien sonné et non non pas du tout vous
avez également de la vidéo mais j'ai pas
vous recommander un là vous êtes sur
votre grand-angle on peut passer ensuite
sur l'ultra grand angle la qualité n'est
pas nécessairement là non plus ce n'est
pas stabilisée il manque quelque chose
voilà c'est pas le smartphone que je
vais venir vous recommander ici pour
venir faire de la vidéo pour venir faire
de la photo mais dans l'idée de la
productivité de pouvoir venir faire
quelques petites photos en plus et
pourquoi pas quelques souvenirs mais pas
plus que ça et c'est vrai qu'à
smartphone à plus de 1500 euros on
s'attendrait autre chose en terme de
qualité photo mais une fois de plus ici
et on le voit vraiment le parti pris par
microsoft ce n'est pas de faire un
smartphone grand public et de s'inscrire
dans ce que font les concurrents haut
niveau la photographie on est plus sur
un usage beat oublie on est plus sur les
tâches professionnelles usage de
productivité dans lequel l'appareil
photo aura sa place mais ne sera pas du
tout lusage prépondérant loin de là
sans gaming pouvait venir jouer à des
jeux en plein écran mais c'est parce que
je veux dire vous recommander ici parce
que je suis pas fait pour vous avez
cette espèce de grande charnière au
milieu cette séparation et c'est pas
dingue vous l'avez montré sa première
version pour mettre à sac 9 ans grand
écran eh bien il sait regarder asphalte
9 est venu bosser et à modifier le truc
merci de jouer en mode paysage pour une
expérience optimale alors je vais me
dire ok c'est pas grave je le mets en
grèce malte 9 et là je peux mais de la
même manière regardez c'est pas ouf est
ce que vous avez envie de jouer avec
neuf comme ça non donc si vous l'achetez
pour jouer au grand écran comme ça en
mode tablette très clairement c'est pas
fait pour vous voyez les limites si vous
voulez venir jouer vous prenez votre
application vous la mettez sur une
partie et vous jouer comme ça et c'est
intéressant d'ailleurs parce que xbox
game passe multimed vous allez avoir
votre jeu sur le haut et sur le bas vous
allez à votre manette virtuelle donc on
va l'utiliser comme une console à deux
écrans n'est pas pour jouer en plein
écran donc on voit que pour tout ce qui
va être multimédia et gaming on va
utiliser un écran et pas deux et c'est
un peu l'idée de ce produit là c'est le
multitâche celle utilisée si vous
souhaitez que sur un écran ou sur deux
écrans en même temps pour voir deux
applications distinctes ou alors des
applications qui sont complètement
optimisé comme avec xbox la manette le
jeu n'est pas en plein écran parce que
ça ne marchera pas par contre cette fois
ci ils ont mis le paquet en terme de
performance snapdragon 888 vous avez 8
gigas de ram c'est de la lpddr2 5 vous
avez soit 128 soit 256 soit 512 giga de
stockage ici non extensible l'autonomie
va pas être folle folle non plus vous
arrivez à une bonne journée avec une
batterie de 4450 méliand période c'est
un point qui était pas terrible sur la
première version il s'ils ont augmenté
un peu la capacité de batterie mais sans
forcément aller beaucoup plus loin on va
regarder maintenant les points positifs
les points négatifs ce que j'aime ce que
j'aime pas ce que je vais mais ici c'est
toute l'expérience logiciel que je
trouve optimisé est intéressante et on
le voit ne serait ce qu'au travers des
paramètres alors une fois de plus ces
paramètres on va venir les mettre au
milieu pour bien voir tout faux c'est
très malin d'avoir ces paramètres comme
ça vous l'avez par code couleur comme ça
on comprend vraiment dans quelle
catégorie on se situe on à la barre n'a
perçu c'est plutôt bien fait assez
intuitif assez malin ça me convient bien
y'a un truc intéressant si au niveau de
l'écran et s'en va venir regarder ici
regardez le thème sombre c'est ce qui
conviendra le mieux ici si vous enlevez
le thème sombre ça va faire apparaître
les bords de cet écran et ses voix c'est
un peu ça aussi la limite c'est pour ça
qu'on a des grandes bordure en eau et
des grandes bordure en bas c'est pour
cette petite charnière qui va venir
tenir un peu l'histoire et c'est vrai
que on aimerait avoir un grand écran
total ça ajouterait en immersion et on
voudrait également que la partie de
l'écran aille plus loin à l'intérieur
ici pour éviter de se retrouver avec
cette bande noire lorsque vous regardez
comme ça en plein milieu c'est eux que
sa rivale sur une version suivante ce
qui serait vraiment intéressant si
l'écran elle est vraiment au bout du
dubout et bien cette partie là elle se
ferait oublier maintenant d'un point de
vue technologique tout de suite on
n'était pas encore qu'on va remettre le
thème sombre je t'aime sombre ici sert à
quoi il sert à faire venir oublier ses
grandes bordure en haut et en bas pour
se retrouver quelque chose de beaucoup
plus immersif un autre truc qui est
intéressant c'est que les couleurs par
défaut elle soit en naturel moi je les
ai poussés en vif s'avérer saturé
davantage tout en restant convenable
autre point qui est intéressant c'est le
capteur d'empreintes digitales qui est
situé sur la tranche qui marche très
très bien qui est extrêmement réactif
dans sa déroute très très rapidement un
autre truc est super bien si les haut
parleurs azote qui sont vraiment
améliorée c'est qu'en fait vous avez un
haut parleur qui situe juste en haut ici
un haut parleur qui s'était juste en bas
et sisto classe très très bête mais
c'est vraiment vraiment malin pourquoi
parce qu'en fait que vous regardiez une
série comme ça faisait les beaux
parleurs ici qu'ils vont envoyer du son
vous allez avoir le haut parleur ici qui
va envoyer du son donc on va avoir du
son comme ça et comme ça pour autant sa
s'obstrue pas on n'a pas le boucher en
posant le doigt sur le côté c'est
vraiment vraiment planqué ici ça venir
significativement l'expérience
multimédia vous venez écouter de la
musique très facilement spotify c'est
bien regarder un film c'est agréable ça
apporte en spatialisation tout ça
vraiment vraiment bien vu quelque chose
de très malin que nous a fait microsoft
ici c'est la petite barbe vous avez la
petite barre d'état qui est planqué ici
je me fais un petit double tape là ça
vient d'afficher l'heure alors c'est pas
toujours très simple à dire parce qu'il
faut un peu se pencher voit qu'il est
17h36 en fait c'est votre écran incurvé
qui vient plus un intérieur qui nous
permet de voir ça donc s'il pouvait
aller encore plus loin cet écran incurvé
on en verrait davantage et ça ça a un
autre sens le branche eh bien ça me
permet de voir mon état de rechargement
cet écran est intéressant pourquoi parce
que lorsque vous le tenez fermé vous
avez un petit écran eh oui si vous avez
un petit écran de 5,8 pouces aujourd'hui
5,8 pouces sans regarder du contenu
multimédia où je vois déjà c'est petit
c'est pour ça que cet appareil n'est pas
forcément fait pour le multimédia et
pour le divertissement parce
qu'aujourd'hui on veut des grands écrans
et là vous avez un petit écran et
lorsque vous l'ouvrez vous arrivez à 8,3
pouces et 8 3 pouces c'est quoi et bien
c'est quasiment la taille d'un ipad mini
et vous le prenez et que vous le posez
dessus vous êtes quasiment aux
dimensions d'un ipad mini heures jeudi
des quasiment pas ce que vous avez les
grandes bordure en haut et en bas mais
presque on est à mi chemin entre un
smartphone et une tablette c'est une
tablette pour le multitâche mais c'est
pas une tablette telle qu'on l'entend
aujourd'hui très grande non à côté de ça
vous a quand même un taux de
rafraîchissement de 90 ans donc ça
portera de la fluidité lorsque j'allais
dire naviguer scrollé puis jouer à des
jeux vous aller jusqu'à 800 dit en
termes de lui does it et et vous avez un
corning gorilla glass pictus qui va
venir le protégé ici maintenant ce n'est
pas dingue c'est que cet appareil ne
serait pas repartent pas si vous avez vu
sortie depuis le début d'année je crois
les indices de réparabilité ça vous
permet de savoir si votre appareil va se
réparer facilement si vous avez une
panne ici vous avez un indice de
réparabilité de 3,9 sur dix c'est je
crois la plus mauvaise note que j'ai
jamais vu donc il faut savoir que si
jamais il vient à tomber en panne vous
le préparez paraît donc ici d'un cadre
de la garantie et bien microsoft fera ce
qu'il faut sinon bien une fin qui
cassent icas donc ça vaut le coup ici de
venir prendre une assurance
il faut savoir et à notre point qui est
pas dingue c'est qu'ici vous n'avez pas
de bloc de chars vous avez uniquement un
câble de recharge mais pas de bloc tout
en sachant que votre câble c'est de
l'usbc usb c'est par contre à la
différence de ce qu'on n'avait pas sur
la génération précédente on n'avait pas
de 5 g ça y est ici on a de la 5g basto
lui on est un qualcomm snapdragon 888
qui permet d'avoir la salle j'ai donc ou
rouge et vous avez en plus du wifi 6 du
nsc du bluetooth cinq points bref tout
ce qui va bien dans cet appareil là
c'est un produit qui est fait pour les
amoureux de microsoft pour tous ceux qui
veulent de la productivité avec
microsoft alors on peut avoir de la
productivité en dehors de microsoft si
vous voulez l'acheter pour venir
regarder un film une série vous le
mettez en mode tant que vous venez
regarder votre contenu comme ça pour
jouer un jeu également sur un écran de 5
à 28 pouces pourquoi pas mais uniquement
sur un écran de 5 2 8 pouces passe sur
un écran d'une bulle de pousse donc à
côté quand même à bout frustrant par
contre le travail qu'a fait microsoft
ici en termes de puissance en terme de
performances en termes d'âge our global
à l'expérience c'est vraiment bien et
très différent par rapport à la
précédente génération il aurait dû
sortir directement ce produit là et ça
aurait évité toutes les critiques qu'ils
ont eue sur la première génération de la
surface duo 1 maintenant faut-il acheter
à 1599 euros et bien si vous êtes en
recherche d'un produit pour la
productivité et faire du multitâche à
usage plutôt professionnel c'est super
intéressant et c'est un très joli
produit si maintenant vous voulez un
produit grand public accès
divertissement axée gaming non bien sûr
que non mais pour autant j'aime beaucoup
cette microsoft surface du o2 je ne
doute pas qu'elle trouvera son public
mais par contre à publiques assainies
chez avec des ventes assez réduite
néanmoins certains à microsoft d'arriver
avec un produit en plus dans sa gamme
accès mobilité portabilité et ça j'aime
beaucoup comment vous trouvez ce
microsoft surface dure eux marqué le
mois juste en bas moi j'aime bien c'est
beaucoup plus dépendants génération
c'est très atypique mais ça me plaît à
bientôt
[Musique]